こんにちははじめ社長ですみんなで
マエケン掴んでます半永久的に出ないかの
スーパーゴッド会の肇社長なんだけども
今回どうしても行ってみたいっがありまし
てターンだられたことないと思いますから
ないですねマイカに厨房を繰り返すために
私は思ってしまいました出前100万円分
頼んだらどうなるぞ
はっはっはバカとか言わないでパーカーと
か言わないで下さい近代までの普通中の
手前1万円分たのみたとかで1万円
食べれるか同カードはねぇやる冬野菜を
安くはない一高いと1枚タダ動画的に言う
と安いなと1万
03年本当に入って述べ前で100万円分
頼んでみたいと思います昨日のうちにお手
舞種厨ボード訳したのであと100万円分
今から届きますすでに当日は大迷惑だと
思ったって今が100万円部冒険が食べ
たいものを片っ端から届くよね私
100万円までどれぐらいなのかそして
[音楽]
食べきることができるのかさっそくやって
いきたいとおもいます女はイバー
いうわけで気
事務所のブームにつきマスター
沢山の社員さんが働いているので
声が出してないいい立つ絶対100万円分
起きないので広いこのスペースを借りて
100万円分じゃないか
静かに頼んで行きたいと思いますそうぞ
たぶんちょっと切らせたもので早速机に
おいていきましょう届きました
まずはお寿司を頼みましたシャアモン
づくしですそれも2つ私が基本的に
サーモンしか食べれないのでサーモン
づくしとあ山に行く
リク星を2つ頼みますかだいたいこれで
サーバー委員会ですね皆さんわかります
これでだいたい3万円ぐらいなんであの
すごく強くなってきましたどんなトップと
いう組んでおりていきたいとおもいます
オードブル届きましたやばい王道で届きて
きたもう重ねないといけないぐらいになり
ました結構訪れた分なんですけどもこの量
で11万円くらいでした宴ですね宴もう
起きなくなってきたで机をちょっと増設し
ていきます4付け方にもう彼らず1万円
メンタルだから近郊形を頼みました個人的
に好きなお稲荷さんとか中華料理系も
めっちゃ美味しそうに声をつまみ系とか
オサレなやつとかサラダそして
サンドイッチ唐揚げ
何かバカみたいな焼きそばもた述べました
よし
誘導2番発券分です龍堂の特防に20個
食べましたやばいなお店みたいになってる
んです
なぁ届きました一番目前ですサラダ起き
ましたちょっと悪くなるんでまだ開けない
んですけど超店にあるの全種類頼みました
駒がには6000やばいなヤバイぞ
これなんかポテトとハンバーガーになっ
てるんですけどもこれもまだ開けるのは
取っておきましょう
[音楽]
いざ202,000円7枚ですカツサンド
12前一番5,000円快晴の32名
4万円です
特盛です韓国っぽい弁当15人前
26,000円明日プロローグでに人前な
んで全部で52枚ありますバスター8年
発生これが多分今回頼んだやつの一匹1
[音楽]
ブーバよこれもう
デザードで16万トンだとリンクで50人
前分44000でブラック講義とかた票
カードが色々食べておりました全部ひとり
で飲みます
ええええええ
えええ
ぬ
[音楽]
はいというわけで生まれ館で100万円た
のんびりましたーーー
carすごいこんな読みたいとない多分
なかなか100万円で by する人もい
ないと思ってプレはで二度と見れない光景
だと思っています落ちた分雨の事務所を
借りないとこんなに食べませんでした
200万円に頼んだんですけども南天た
ノンタ100万円以下というとだいたい
500点ぐらい食べましたでもうすぐ発車
ネットもあるし sa 詰まる時バラバラ
なんですけどもだいたい500個頼めば
100万円くらいになるんだってください
わかりました
ここでめちゃくちゃお得なキャンペーンの
お知らせです出前館で初めての注文で擁立
的なクーポンがありません2600以上の
注文でなんと
2500円を2600円向かうと
2500円もありますだから実施に
100円で買えま期間の今日から1週間
ほどで先着10万名様になるのでぜひ皆
さん使ってみてくださいクーポンコード
こちらになります始め01使ってみて
くださいさらに待ってマイカーま it 3
県で陶料無料キャンペーンを実施中です
今回のこの100万円かっていつも方が
創業無料だったね皆ぜひ使ってみて
くださいでは早速 web 飛びでいます
さぁづ上去すぐひとりで全部食べていき
ましょう選び防災すぎるぞ
自分とれたんですよね
全部食べますよジャパン所は早速山にあん
のなぁにいただきます何個食べたでもって
こう消すたぴおかというかマンゴの
タピオカ持っているルーどうもーいただき
ます
なぜじゃあこれぐらいにした褐色
てみれてきためっちゃすぐスチーム出てき
ましたけどもいただきます疲れたので
ちょっと竪琴飲ませていただきます
[音楽]
うめぇまあまああと歌うだけを縦断
いただきます警報だかすごいもう先にな人
いるこの食べちゃっていただきます
花田を食べます何でも食べ放題やな欲しい
物すぐにそこにあるからん
をなぜていただきます
もうウォン
何食べようかなぁ
いらっしゃいません
水着が欲しい変わってきます史実経験マジ
で美味しそうなんでしょ
様子が全部を力なんだろう
[音楽]
を
ごちそうさまでした
してません
分かっていたんですけど
1人し全部食べることできまー100万円
分北頼んでみたかっただけで全部食べれる
とはもう元から持ってなかったんで
ちょっとから思ってなかったんですけども
この海の事務所でたくさんのスタッフさん
が働いているということで僕が食べれなく
てもこれだけたくさん料理があれば社員
さんみんなお腹いっぱいにできるかなと
思って日頃の感謝を込めて僕はこれは自分
で全部食べるんですけども残りはああああ
いう部のスタッフさん全員にちょっと
プレゼントというか今日はお昼ごはんにし
ていただきたいなと思いますじゃあ
さっそく配っていきましょう
午後お願いいたします
まいがー
次のねー
てください
[音楽]
ん
憲法生産
見てくれません
[音楽]
ないとおっしゃること a
今日はぼくの思い出へ
そう金で食う飯がうめえかー
その子そんなこと1ミリも思ってませんよ
惨めにオン対戦動画の通りです
んん
早野まあ間違えて食べれないと思ってたよ
見たかっただけなんで100万円ってどれ
くらいなんだろうってこれを見越してまう
上でやっていたと言っても過言ではない
なんかすごい皆さん喜んでくださったので
あなんかほっこりした素敵な動画になり
ましたでただいまですね出前館のはじめし
たそのコラボキャンペーン実施中です
チンキクーポンを利用した方の中から抽選
で100名様に熱中外から使える5千円
居るクーポンプレゼントです
あの母性はマジでデカイですよ戦やったら
何食べます詳しくは動画概要欄から
チェックしてみてくださいすぐお得な
キャンでめっちゃ多いなあタイヤ6すげー
楽しかったなぁ
あった
次はでばいい1000枚分頼んだらどう
なるのでお会いしましょうじゃあ
dl
[音楽]